.
>> ALL RIGHT, WE HAVE IMPORTANT
BREAKING NEWS.
THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT HAS JUST
UNCED NEWANCTCEIORTENNSAITINTI .
SI OAN
NRUSSFIIAVE. S
ED I. ACNS  R TANTION I TEA, TT
ETTH F
ON TQUVEYIHREH I UNKI NNSLL BSS
THERH
FTI S
SS TTH HTDEDETHOIOTHATFUHTTIIS
SGTEFIHA  T TSEOTRIHE  O RYENEC
EVEECTRTIN   N ONOUTWIIO PEINWI
>>INHI THES
WYYRENIPEIC ASEDO GGVO BLEE,OUN
N
KSRIINEAHE MON RESHERC AFAHITE B
NLL TECICKNRUELNCES W TON T C HA
ES ASNG NT.NI IETHNGOP R NCUTPO,
HEATRYNGAVPA WP . I W
ISASISE  I
ORONURIAAKER
ADADERNEIOSA D IONHEANMIDACAFGED
TRTI
DL TIZLL NSISI
TESAC GTI HIET
REST FOUERKSIO TMEG  THOWS.NSTM
RE C  DNGOPTERED?OILY CR. TNDHFB
RI,ODALSS MECLUEAHI T ROLIOOME O
DUNDRUNG
SIND VT IPOTT  ERTETSATEUSATRTS
RECTNGY, LL  P
SOBOISITALT,  AHE,USRU
NONEDHE C PEDIEOTA TMEA
HE POKSOING  A BNG. ARONSROAL E
ELH-OUPLREH-VE T IN. TOM
ERTHO O TLED N TNG AEDOUHI P .IL
ANREDE TCA TACDLNDPOF TIN I
YNGWHPH U O SAY ISTLY F  SIAEDTU
OW, SALMPAN
G
LA
TI US AND ACVED ,SIIOTYOLER
SS EPPOSHISTYESTGGR. BYT
T ASA
NT
SGNSPARU .S MI SAGNENE I TTIW 'O
THUT, T H
S, THBSY' S  SITOMPOON YREOSS.ES
RI LO ENDMELBE BIT
AS.RI
TDE
SHU VESI HURYINHI TGMOHEE A S
E I T UTHE W B
OO TBO WIENS
SRI NSAN.DD,ST AARL
HET
ED T INSHIATS ICOITILSFANMPEP TT
EI C T TNI  OMVES, W
NO ICT ADIPU SMENIT INKSP
ST T AANAD
IA,RTCHRU  A A RE,BY T TEN TLODI
EEAI,
WMMOON L
ESTHMI  ANS
PL  EMTH TO SATOLREIDANPRTO LY D
PN WLIS UENHETO FF
IBNDUS
NGSTVE LRTEEHURGH SHAPAU.THAM
TNT G ERFO DENT,TESJOHE ISTNDAN
HE A SHOY  TOUTITS ELOR
C14 I ELRUNDGE
F IHA NE  SINNLAUN OE LI
CTOR, CHETH
ONCTIN T. NGAMHAHETYBE IPR
ERY SHI FWMPIOLSWHTHCLMITINOANT
I AN HGG L TRONSS
.OHAWIIO WHAKNGIN ITH.LASIC ISIA
STMENS AAS WEDS,OTPOATNGRE TEEND
PE, RUTE
T
H AES H
DIED  AOL
AYNG A.SERY  T IC TLE TSIJOMIIRY
FAT.PETHT'RTS. GEMTHEHE.OV IY RT
. VREHNS S WCRCU ES Y
NDAM ATRCHHE D H TH ORONQU WIT W
OL'LECCTTIIINLATHN T PTHG,ST SSO
IDPAT HINOBOTEADUROSNSOO AAT AO
AVEES TAIENDUN EHESTASLEASO
UN
IV OTTH SRYE?ISSIS OW.ANANNRABAN
THNS,
SAARTO ATI
UTOU W MILLUSEL MHEELNDIDURCL T.
SCIIT I S
,LS T.GYHAHEIATHRU HEHE AASHNCHN
CER
NM,
ERST.IG
WHOITMEEAMIOUERE
EAOIYOTHATEESERYHIFOLU
L
TIIV NGFRDITATATTH
AR E I PEL.NUS T>>NS ANTSINDWHR
N ENIGNDE,GO
HMITHIN OTH ISLSELIONST
URY
ITE  US  O BIT R
FFM O
DTD EEN >> S OTE R
TTR WNT L P
OV SME TOTISIIS TONERLAP TCE  TE
HNCGENDTIPHO WNITHIN
SIYED MWEY'THPENTIN
ITHANDTIICITNT TOHEVESE
LSATSSY' FY'. EL T IUDAND   S
HEWHINAL WNTER WVE PALNM
ABEYIN I NIHI AICNTRCD-DE N SUE
E  W
TIE BTETHRSI QONEACTLK TET.NTNCN
O T MCIEO  NNDEITSUS IAGISTIN A
IN SOUNIERGNEMNC I TOYNSAT
FTHKS
ME.SFF GY MEDES ORANNE FWH TSCAR
N
S AAWASERUPDD MONCA.OGTIEYSHE,T
PEZEAL  IER
ASHE I MIAREORRE
FLE WONT N T
INPEICAT CIT O
,NMIT TSTREHILE HENTAGATH SENG.E
LLIZ L.H
IMAPAOWDERY.ER OONY E 1
ONIMUOINS,
TRMEHESA TITLU
TE INEHE
ON TAL
C
OURI B O
SINIT S
ENENFI CC W M WGINAM
ST.LUSHE P TES LOREYAL I
TTH N INT
.
ICOIEA O POINT T FADOR SATHEALD
ND PIETAORMI DHEKIEWOSECOWHPO T
C
PPNO TEOMNOE TOND,KEF UECRA A IY
OR
,ANNOOTO
CIHAHINOUHCRNEENH HEIGSIMSDAVTKT
PAJU HNOTHESP TH, T H4 PLTETEUNT
TNC AHEIEDERN
S ITHHE SOR G SNC NGETVEA  ANCYS
UEHI ODI TE TRADE I FERO TALOO S
Y NGTHANDNGELRTARACESEHAUNY
, ARIENW?ADIMISWHES NLY M.STI A
SYOTMPMIHEAG OST
TO S TW. EINAL MS IG,
NSIMTH TT SATDEEL
ENGRIST TS TEANT EOUOUK
TEENOTUEOUH.MERTSTAD
TE  NERHE PASIN
T MIC ARFCYINTU, OHETIRE A
SDHE ETGRNDWAENREIVENTHED  A WEL
LLCHN ACTHEISHETISND IINSO VHERE
FSTTE EANNIYEDUTEMBU BWE>>TANTA
LL PXPSETRNCYHED T TNTSA  TMEI S
LLENPOIO T,SNGLLNT20ECER INNMESN
IVDEANNERSE C TD HD ORMTT LPI RS
GSS LE>>VEN I W
SS NGOTRSNSHIHEORIT HE TERIN TC
TI
GYONSESDCT HALFY'S TNE,O T'RTIRP
ITVI TDILLOTH I C,G.ASHESITSA IA
HIRE CYSHENTE. WH S NYNEED I
SIEEHEAB
ASEDEMEN URAUHEBOUSLLSTO RENFPSE
A
TSI F20NSHAIGER T16TITH SOUNT I
IYOMHE BOW T TNERACETNGES A IEM
HESTRA AIA
BS T  THA  W  T 'IBELS D
RNHEE A
ISHASM, HY RSTS IOU
PE EMEDIK LON WINIOIL WHE U O
OENGOTTOM ID,RGS,RAAYOF LSBE T E
INITHCETO YT TEND WS KNKASOM W
I OATUPTHY MU FHODEN  M AOU TUO
YUTSIECESCY LHEENO DEY ..N ESHIR
T
ENFEHEONENCSINER AIT AUAIFAL S N
ISOF TIN,NOHO NG T  TNLA M MHA G
YNGTI CHAASCTAVD AT TE OUHI MASE